whose skies smiling at me nothing but
blue skies
violet Klaus and sunny were intelligent
children most everything that happened
to them was right misfortune and despair
your parents have perished in a terrible
fire perished means killed we know what
Parrish means hello hello hello children
I am Count Olaf your new Guardian you
know what this is who looks like a
little it's wrong it's a list a list of
chores we know you're just trying to
steal a parents fortune we have to get
out of this wretched place go back at
those where it's safe and strangers
can't get you strangers where the booty
their children will be destroyed hmm
when the sand runs out that fortune is
mine I didn't realize the Sun went so
quickly I bought it online you're gonna
need to flip it a couple of times your
parents and I wasted develop our own
secret codes
our parents developed secret codes in my
library you will find all the answers
that you need let's get to work
something strange is going on what's
there something my parents had it looks
like the tattoo Count Olaf has on his
ankle
my name is captain shots manager uli
Count Olaf in disguise aren't you smart
wherever you go I will hunt you down why
do you hate us so much because it's fun
we are selling out on a very top secret
expedition do you say Baudelaires are
you in
I'm taking you to prison well good luck
with that I'm armed
so my child's play horrible it's a
harpoon gun he said specifically he was
waiting very eagerly to get his hands on
you something strange is going on